ferm also calls some of Jacksonville's
worst flooding in more than 150 years
water from the st. Johns River and
Atlantic Ocean rose into the downtown
area and several neighborhoods the Coast
Guard and firefighters rescued dozens of
people
Jericka Duncan is in Jacksonville where
victims are waiting for the water to
recede
Jericka good morning good morning in
this Riverside community these folks
here got that flood water the worst and
the mayor says that things could
actually get worse because this flood
water is expected to rise and fall
gradually over the next several days the
st. Johns River flowed into downtown
Jacksonville and riverfront communities
the National Weather Service called it a
serious event we have already surpassed
historic levels the levels will continue
to rise we are in rescue mode right now
Jacksonville Mayor Lenny curry says
mandatory evacuations were ordered on
Friday there are some that didn't
evacuate in certain areas and many areas
along the river combine that with the
fact that we have had historic
unprecedented storm surge
emergency crews including the Coast
Guard and local firefighters combed
through neighborhoods looking for people
trapped by rising waters more than 100
have been rescued
southeast of jacksonville hurricane Irma
sent beach homes sliding into the sand
and in nearby Atlantic Beach powerful
winds toppled dozens of trees this one
barely missing Donna mounts home she
says she and her husband planned to stay
at a hotel but the hotel closed due to
evacuation orders so we kind of hunker
down and it was fine until this happened
and thank goodness it's not you know it
didn't hit us at all now about 150,000
people are without power 150,000 homes
rather and the situation again is still
not exactly going to get any better
because of these flood waters that are
in these neighborhoods but officials are
telling folks to be careful there are a
lot of downed trees there are a lot
there's a lot of debris everywhere so
right now we're really looking at the
cleanup phase which starts today oh boy
a lot of work to do Jericka you be
careful - thank you very much